Introducing PrintSnap.
The PrintSnap camera brings back the excitement of instant pictures.
Simply load, flip and shoot.
Within a few short seconds,...
...you'll have a photo that you can share with your friends or post to your wall.
Just like digital pictures, PrintSnap photos can be easily edited and cropped.
And if you're worried about privacy,...
...rest assured that PrintSnap photos are easy to delete securely.
If you like Instagram filters,...
...there are dozens of great filters that are compatible with PrintSnap.
You can even make your own.
And with its optional time-lapse add-on, you can take stunning time-lapse videos.
Because the PrintSnap uses low-cost thermal paper for printing,...
...each exposure costs just three tenths of a cent.
And it doesn't use any ink.
And with its powerful rechargeable battery,...
...PrintSnap can take hundreds of pictures on a single charge.